obviously most people think of chicago
style pizza as deep dish in the pan i
hate that you hate deep dish i went with
a food critic to one of these pizza
areas in chicago i walked out no yeah
did not pass the wolfgang puck vibe
check
[Music]
if you think chicago pizza is all about
deep dish you've got it all wrong for
decades ultra thin tavern style pizza
has been the dominant slice in the windy
city and for this bar pizza showdown i'm
going head to head with stephen cusado
from the youtube channel not another
cooking show steve is a student of
regional cooking styles and an overall
whiz in the kitchen so i know he's going
to bring the heat today pizza this good
calls for a pair of iconic judges
wolfgang puck is a certified legend in a
pizza game thanks to his smoked salmon
pies at spago and adam richmond is a
food tv trailblazer who ate his way
across the country on man vs food will
adam and wolfgang appreciate my take on
the tavern style pie there's only one
way to find out
steve casado is in the building today
i'm so happy you're here thank you for
having me i couldn't be more excited to
be making pizzas with you today all
right well let's get right into it we're
doing tavern style that's right now what
made you want to jump into tavern style
what i do on the show is i get obsessed
with like a classic dish and i try and
figure out like what makes that so good
and how to make it in my vision the
interesting thing about tavern style
pizza is that it's really thin it's like
a cracker right and
that kind of makes it a little
complicated to make too many toppings
you have a problem two little toppings
it's no good if the crust isn't crispy
all the way through the bottom then
you're gonna have problems so
it seems simple it's rather complicated
but we're gonna give it a shot today i
think you're gonna give it a great shot
so step one i got my dough so in new
york you might see them tossing with the
hands this is a little bit more of a
delicate dough we want to get it as thin
as we can and it's going to be perfectly
crisp and we got this thing called a
docker or just something like that
it's just going to allow any of the air
bubbles to kind of be inhibited and then
we're going in with the sauce we're
swapping out tomatoes for vodka sauce
i'm just gonna gently work that around
the pizza now that we've got our sauce
on the methodical
application of toppings begins and we're
gonna start with
reggiano and then we're going to grate
low moisture mozzarella okay and then on
top of the low moisture marshmallow
we're going to use dried fresh
mozzarella it looks good next we want to
do
is the pepperoni and so now with the
jalapenos i'm looking at like the the
spaces in between the pepperoni right
next up we're going bell pepper and then
on top of that sliced onion okay and
then i have a little bit of oregano that
goes right on top so all the toppings
are on there it's looking good i'm happy
with it it's time to get it in there all
right let's go
it's ready so we're going to pull out
the pizza
oh that booty is looking good it's got a
nice crust so we're just going to let it
sit okay in the meantime i'm going to
make a little hot honey
we love that all that we're gonna do is
take a little bit of honey and then some
sriracha and here's the square cut okay
you've just got these great little
squares they're just so devourable once
you pop you can't stop i know should we
try yes i already know which one i want
this one right yeah first i just want to
admire your creation it's like paper
thin
now i'm gonna eat it
mmm
i'm happy with it the possibilities for
something like this are endless
but i think at the end of the day
this is how i want it
and i'm enjoying the slice i mean come
on
that crunch
all right steve are you ready to see
what i'm gonna do i'm dying let's do it
so the first thing we're gonna do is
roll this dough out super duper thin but
i also want it to be not too thin so it
could support the toppings yeah it's a
delicate balance with this now that my
dough is in my pan stretched all the way
out i'm gonna dock it i like to dock it
around in a circle so i get all the way
to the end of the crust so now what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna take my sauce just
my regular marinara sauce i usually use
i also like the burnt cheese on the
edges so what i have here is some
cheddar cheese just for a little weight
i'm just going to put a little bit of
the cheese i'm going to use in the
center here so i'm going to put this in
the oven
and we're going to par bake in three to
four minutes
now it's time to take this baby out and
top it i just put down the mozzarella
shred it i just love the way it melts
different and now i'm gonna add some
fontina and that's gonna make it gooey
and we want gooey so now i got the
pickled green tomatoes i have some
italian sausage but i toasted some
fennel and i threw it in there and just
seasoned it nice i love a good pepperoni
on a tavern pie like pepperoni is just
supposed to be on a butterfly i was like
oh my gosh nicole you're always doing so
much but i had to add a little pepperoni
to it too i'm gonna finish this bake
then i'm gonna take it out this pan put
it directly on the steel so we can get
that bottom nice and crispy you ready
wow beautiful thanks go
[Music]
[Applause]
it smells delicious i got it it's
smoking whoo
so that's my thin crust
look at the booty booty's looking kind
of nice that's looking kind of nice all
right so let's finish this bad boy off
so the hot ones nugget honey it has a
little heat inside so let's drizzle some
of this on here and then now we're gonna
garnish the arugula really just
brightens the whole look to it huh yeah
it looks good i gotta say looks like i'm
in trouble very legit crust underneath
nice darkness not burnt
[Music]
so hot it's very delicious the crust is
crispy the sauce tastes good the cheese
combinations i don't know that tomato in
there i'm in trouble you know your pie
was amazing i'm pleased with my pie but
we've got pizza legend wolfgang puck in
the building that's why we're sweating
it's an iconic moment for both of us
iconic and then to add to iconic we got
tv icon adam richman he's my man i love
him man versus food legendary legendary
and hopefully they love both of us and i
think they will we're both winners in my
books we are all winners there's no
losers on piece awards no no no
all right well you know i adore you
admire you respect you obviously you
helped change the pizza game have you
had chicago tavern style before most
people think of chicago style pizza as
deep dish in the pan i hate it you hate
deep dish i [ __ ] hate it why do you
hate it because it's a mess it's not the
pizza i like the thin crust i like when
the bottom is crispy i remember i went
with the food critic to one of these
pizza areas in chicago i walked out no
yeah did not pass the wolfgang puck vibe
check but see the chicago tavern style
is so thin it's like cracker cracker
thin could you judge
all kinds of pizza by the same yardstick
if i put a detroit style and i put a
thin crust pizza side by side would you
have to change the criteria that you
judge by you know it's delicious or not
delicious it sucks oh it's delicious
fair enough so we have two pizzas to try
yeah we will determine if they suck or
if they're delicious okay good god i
love how cold you are man
[Music]
okay so this is pie number one are you a
center guy or an okay i guess i'm gonna
get what you'll get
okay
you know this would be a good pizza to
serve
at the cocktail party for example a
little bit of history lesson
that's how chicago bar pizza was started
yeah that's why it's called tavern style
you wouldn't need plates you'd have
little cocktail napkins yeah and you
would literally pass slices down to
people at the bar what do you think of
it
i like the
jalapeno on it it gives it a little
spice
i don't know if it's the combo the bell
pepper the onion the jalapeno it almost
reminds me of like a mexican pizza the
edges get a little more dry a little
more you cook the center has like a
juiciness to it and i really got that
honey yeah no i think it's very good
i'll actually like the outside too
because it's crispy and i think it has a
nice crunch to it so it's really
an interesting way and you know i make
my own style but i think i'll always
love to see something new and this is
really i think a good pizza i think so
all right we've already demolished half
of this pizza we have a lot more to go
you ready i'm ready i'm still hungry too
let's do it bring on pizza too please
all right pizza number two what is your
first reaction i think it looks a little
heavier than the first one
i think it has more cheese on it
obviously also it has some
loose sausage on it right very
traditional chicago i think it looks
good you want a little taste i would
love a taste
so many things going on yeah the toasted
fennel too was also really prominent
uh-huh i love the fennel i love the
arugula on it and it's really well done
on the bottom too no more it was smoky
here a little bit now i know where it
came from huh it's the most substantial
yeah of any of the chicago tavern style
i've had it's not as light as the other
one absolutely but i think it works well
together too i think for me maybe a
little bit too much honey so have we
converted you to chicago tavern style no
but i changed my mind i said chicago has
the worst pizza
now i know they have amazing pizza i
love you there you go the boss the guy
the wolf the [ __ ] the gay
all right we have two very delicious
very different pizzas we're gonna have
to
look over the ingredients think about
our experiences and yeah good decision
to make
wolfgang and adam thank you so much for
being here wolfgang this is definitely a
milestone in my career and adam
having you back means the world to me
the stakes are so high because you guys
are like such like oh to both of us so
please tell us what you thought of both
of our pies uh well actually we have a
second trophy
no i wish we did these were two
extraordinarily tasty pizzas what was
your opinion well i think i liked both
of them
i thought for me they could have both
have a little bit more spice on it
because i love spices i think what i
love is the thin crust you both nailed
the crust what's so interesting is you
both did a great job but differently
okay adam wolfgang we gotta know who's
the winner
okay on three
one
two
three
pizza two pizza number two oh
thank you so much is that your pizza
it's my pizza i was not a fan of chicago
style pizza because i saw the only had
deep dish pizza right you guys changed
my mind i'm gonna go back to
chicago and try their pizza i hope it's
as good as what you made i think it will
be i mean we both did our best you guys
both have a lot to be proud of
congratulations w any vodka leftover for
us
i drank it all in preparation of meeting
you
come get your flowers well thank you so
much
[Music]
[Music]
you